I just talked to Steven Spielberg at the
AFI Life Achievement Awards and we just
found out what he's doing next with John
William if you could have one to just
score your life the song starts playing
every time you go to do something big
Star Wars
not even what's your work goin rogue
guys I heard that you had a hand in
picking the new young Han Solo and that
you discovered him in a bot Mitzvah
video he was yes he was in a bot mr.
video that my daughter acted with him in
for their best friend Layla and they
showed me the video and I loved it and I
got him an agent that sort of all began
I thought he had a lot of promise in
comedy I didn't know he was going to go
rogue drama he was so funny in this
video I thought I have found the next
really funny comedian but he's made most
of his choices have been in drama and
people don't know how really funny he is
I gotta ask you really quick about
Indiana Jones 5 will John Williams come
back and for John Williams will come
back and score absurd